why why does that interest you both in
particular do you feel that
relationships are in crisis there's
people men aren't allowed to have
standards in society and that's just
like the one thing I noticed like
whenever men say that they want
something in a relationship like women
always shame them for it no no you
should have said you should have said
the city hall the city hall yeah but so
what do you mean by that I think we know
what she means yeah yeah no no no but
but let's talk what does that what does
that mean because it's sleeping okay I
met one girl
women will play the victims when they
started it like you can't hit a guy and
not expect to get hit back
that's that's
interesting I think we should teach the
women not to hit someone stronger than
them and they'll say like men are
responsible for all
you know but I really think you found
them
I recently decided that women shouldn't
vote decided women shouldn't vote yeah
that's a new opinion why is that okay
I'll take one for the team yeah okay you
should have the same opinions you should
be voting for the same person as your
husband why so like I don't know you
want to be in a house where you're
arguing about politics yes yeah I want
someone who thinks differently to me you
had a guy called Nick Fuentes yeah yeah
Nick I did not find Nick to be racist my
staff actually did not find him to be
racist you just did say I am a bit
racist even enough and in fact in your
apology you said that he said racist
things well I'm a bit confused about is
you did a whole apology but it sounds
like you're not asking me about this
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster I'm Constance and kitten
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with Fascinating
People as you know what we do on
trigonometry is talk to people with a
variety of different views our guests
are often outspoken or controversial but
no matter who we're talking to we always
approach our interviews in good faith
that means we let our guests speak don't
misrepresent them and challenge them
respectfully if we disagree a couple of
days ago we interviewed a YouTuber
called just pearly things now in between
booking her to come on the show several
weeks ago and actually doing the
interview on Thursday she hosted a
well-known white supremacist openly
racist Holocaust denier called Nick
Fuentes on her show understandably that
generated a lot of pushback and she
deleted the interview and issued a
lengthy apology
given that we were happy to go ahead
with the interview
and we obviously had to bring up the
situation it's never Our intention to
make our guests look bad but we also
have a duty to ask these questions and
to challenge people when what they're
saying doesn't make sense to us when we
asked about the apology let's just say
things got very awkward very quickly
what you're about to watch is the full
unedited interview we haven't cut or
added anything so that as always you the
viewer can make up your own mind enjoy
our brilliant guest today is a fellow
YouTuber who started her show a year ago
and is now on over a million subscribers
Pearl uh Davis aka just early things
welcome to trigonometry thank you for
having me oh it's awesome thanks so much
for coming it's great to have you on as
I just picked you up you're you've
absolutely smashed it uh before we get
into all of that uh tell everybody who
are you how are you where you are what's
been the journey through life that leads
you to be sitting here talking to us so
my name is Pearl I'm a YouTuber
um I'm from Chicago I live in London I
do a YouTube show here
that was quick yeah how did you decide
to start it how did you have the idea I
just I could tell everybody what the
show is because a lot of people wouldn't
have seen it
I'm sorry that's fine
um so we talk about a lot of men's
issues so I feel like
most media today is Catered towards
women pandering towards women we don't
do that on my channel
it's a woman no
no and pass it to men uh not panda look
it I just say I say things that are true
okay I say things that that are like
basic to me right but like what
you know you shouldn't get super fat
after you get married just because you
got a ring
that's basically
women 50s knew that but today
I'm a bully I'm the meanest person ever
blah blah so so yeah that's what I do is
we talk about relationships on my show
um and so we bring in men and women
women to talk about different like
relationship topics and then we go back
and forth yeah and then I'm also I also
work a lot with um
um the court system here I'm doing a
documentary on men getting custody of
their kids interesting yeah but one of
the things you did with your show and I
don't know if you were one of the first
ones but it's definitely a format that's
really skyrocketed I can't open my
Twitter now without you know eight
people sitting around the table having
some discussion often they don't know
what they're talking about but it's a
format of bringing kind of random people
together but partly random very random
very random very random yeah and you
also have famous people and we'll talk
about that as well but that did you come
up with that was something was that
something that you saw other people
doing like no um I would say fresh and
fit in Miami
um we're probably the first ones to do
that so I went on their show
um and what I liked about London is it
was one of the most like diverse places
I've ever lived yeah so I just thought
it'd be cool to bring everyone in a room
and talk about something that we all
have in common yeah which is
relationships that's very interesting
and so but why do you pick this subjects
that you do why are you drawn to the
subjects that you discuss because they
are controversial they can get you into
hot water
Etc
um I just I follow what interests me and
I just thought those subjects were
interesting it wasn't a lot of people
think it's like a lot more drawn out
every week I'm just like oh that's an
interesting topic and we go for it
um I would say it's a mix of
relationships sometimes we add in some
conservative stuff but it's like mostly
about relationships and and why why does
that interest you both in particular do
you feel that relationships are in
crisis now or we've done value
relationships or we look at
relationships men aren't allowed to have
standards in society and that's just
like the one thing I noticed like
whenever men
say that they want something in a
relationship like women always shame
them for it and I just thought it was so
interesting how we never like talk about
the men's point of view so when I first
started I I started like introducing my
friends to like certain types of content
so I would be like well have you ever
thought about this this way or ever
thought about that that way and I don't
know that's kind of how it started right
so men are ashamed for having standards
what do you mean by that let's just
unpick that a little bit okay so what do
we have we have fat shaming if a guy
says I want a girl in shape oh he's fat
shaming oh if a guy says I don't want
the town [__] you know then he's
slut-shaming you know if he says I don't
want to like it's like anytime a guy
demands something out of a relationship
or he's labeled as controlling and I
just got oh my gosh I got so tired in
the past year I got so tired because I
just feel like I would we would talk
about like basic things and the men
would say basic things that they wanted
and like they would just continue to be
shamed for it and it's just like one of
those things once you see it you can't
unsee it so what what are the basic
things and and look a lot of people who
said you use let's put it fruity
language as they would say in the 1950s
in England like the town hall oh yeah
you should have said the city hall the
city hall yeah but so what do you mean
by that I think we know what she means
yeah yeah no no no but but let's talk
what does that what does that mean
because sleeping okay I met one girl
hahaha
she told me this was off camera she
didn't tell me this on camera
girl because we had a pro-life show
girls had seven abortions seven
she's like 28. it's like madness madness
like you can't tell me that's not
Madness right and so we're just in this
world where it's like girls are doing
this crazy crazy stuff
and if anyone has anything to say about
it we're the bad guys it's just like
don't put me in that group like well
that makes a lot of sense because I
think a lot of people including a lot of
women would be like you've had seven
abortions I mean even if you're
pro-choice you'd sort of not be on board
with that most people you would be
surprised you'd be surprised well you
think you think a lot of people are on
board with that maybe not I'm bored but
like legally oh yeah yeah so here it's
free yeah yeah so
um yeah and do you think that these
particular women don't take
responsibility for their actions do you
think it's Society why would it's like
we live in a world where women are
bailed out of every single bad decision
we make if we want to sleep around
there's birth control if birth control
doesn't work there's abortion if if um
the girl does get pregnant and wants to
keep it she can put the dude on child
support and not let him see the kids
like what a guy gets six days a month
maybe if he's lucky
um on top of that if that doesn't go
well you know they can
give it up for adoption it's like women
are always bailed out of every bad
decision we make I heard here they gave
you free housing if you're a single
mother what incentive do we have to make
good decisions if we get free [__] from
the government for making bad decisions
it's a good point but then surely isn't
the system at fault rather than the
individual pill
why
both I mean I think the system's at
fault for like allowing them to do that
but I mean I think your life is your own
fault yeah so if I you can't tell me a
girl had seven abortions that's not her
fault no no like I agree yeah Francis
always likes to blame the system because
he's an old school Lefty yeah things
about the city no I mean I would say
it's okay there's good people and bad
people but if you have a system that
allows bad people to do or bad people to
get away with the bad things that they
do
then of course
um the system's at fault too however
nah like your own life is your own fault
so I kind of see both sides when it
comes to that yeah and do you is are
these your politics that inform your
world view do you have a political
outlook on life
um I would say I'm like more
conservative but
like no it's just what I see in front of
me like to be honest you know I do
that's the sense I get from you you know
ideological you just go that's stupid
that doesn't work etc right that's my
take on that's my sense of you yeah yeah
yeah yeah okay
gonna say something else though no and
um how how have you found the experience
of like just bringing in because you
just literally do you just grab people
off the street oh gosh
oh that's hell uh recruiting as hell
um yeah basically a year ago I started
with like my teammates but I dunked on
them a little too hard so they stopped
coming on
because this one girl was trying to say
that a guy that likes younger women was
a pedophile and I was just like now I
wasn't talking about underage women okay
I'd like declare don't clip me don't do
that
um but and I was just like
no like that's just natural that's what
men naturally want younger women yeah um
so yeah then they stopped coming on but
no we recruit through Instagram mostly
and so you get a bunch of random people
yes who want to come on the show yes to
discuss these things yes and you clearly
you know as you said you were dunking on
your own teammates too hard so they've
Left Right some of them came back they
did come back
and how how does that go because we do I
mean certainly from our perspective
living a society where as you say people
are very uncomfortable with certain
things that we all know are true being
said out loud in the public I how how
does that go when you get a bunch of
random people and you start dropping
your truth bombs
um sometimes well sometimes not well I
better I've had a lot of girls come back
and say they change their opinions after
coming on my show actually that they see
the world in a completely different way
but I would say the majority hate me
yeah not that come on the show but like
I don't know but that's interesting so
you've had people who've changed their
opinions can you give a couple of
examples of that I had one friend that
stopped being friends with me last year
because I had a post about something
that pissed her off
and um she literally said she stopped
being my friend wouldn't talk to me
whatever she came back three months
later and said you were right
and I was a crazy feminist and I
realized I was wrong and what was the
post
um modern women want to be victims
interesting so let's say so let's
explore let's explore that why do you
think that though
because they play the victim and
everything
okay
but good let's give some examples like
what do you mean by that is it okay okay
so when I started doing the show Girls
would come forward and they would say
like
I was abused right okay and my first
response as like a person is I believe
them right and I and I think you know
you have empathy right but then you find
out that they they didn't press any
charges against the guy
so you're coming on a platform and
you're saying I was afraid to press
charges but you're not afraid to talk on
my show and this has happened multiple
times so people know who her exes that
watch the show so she's publicly
defaming this man's character with no
proof or evidence
and so I just think a lot of times like
or or they wouldn't they wouldn't talk
about how
I would ask the question he hit you okay
did you hit him first and more often
than not they would hit first oh wow
yeah and they didn't talk about that
they would talk so that's what I met as
I was talking about how like women will
play the victims when they started it
like you can't hit a guy and not expect
to get hit back
that's that's interesting why do you say
that because look so from my own
background I was raised whatever
happened whatever you do you never lay
hands on a woman you just never do that
whatever happens you absolutely never do
yeah I mean I I think they tell man that
because they cater to women if you hit
someone expect to get hit back well hold
on Mitch like why is why is she exempt
from any responsibility like okay if you
go up to Dwayne The Rock Johnson and you
punch him in the face is anyone gonna
feel bad when you get hit back no and he
knocks your brains out like why do we
have that men don't have a cop-out for
that but if a woman hits a man who's
stronger than him there's always a
cop-out then she's the victim oh never
hit no offense but never never hit a
woman blah blah blah so you know you hit
him first get out of here and now we're
having cases where men are dying from
women like in Florida where that only
fans model did you guys hear about that
there was an only fans model who um
killed her boyfriend
and
um like at first they thought it was
like a mutually abusive relationship now
CCTV TV footage
I don't know if it's called the same
thing there but elevator footage has
come out and um
like it's of her like literally beating
the [__] out of him
and like what she doesn't deserve to get
hit
I mean I the Equal Rights equal laughs
baby
I guess the counter argument to that is
if a woman hits me uh it's not gonna do
with the vast majority of cases that
much damage now we had Veronica Hardy in
the studio with her husband Dan and
Veronica's a UFC fighter and Veronica
would destroy me in a matter of seconds
but
the reality is I can hit harder than the
vast majority of women and cause more
damage yeah so then it's on the women to
not hit the man why would you hit
someone stronger than you
and this is what I mean like when we
look at Society there's always like a
bailout so even right there like you did
it and I think there's a lot of like
little things that we don't notice in
societies where it's like never hit a
woman why
why like why why does she showed up
dancing to teach your son however there
are exceptions so this one is going to
ask you imagine you're walking down the
street with your girlfriend yeah and a
woman runs over and starts beating up
your girlfriend
yeah never hit a woman
yeah so to me
I would physically restrain her and I
would what if she started beating you up
well I was once if she had enough or a
stick or a [__] okay right okay then
in that case well my whole point in this
is like there see right there that's a
bailout The Woman made a bad decision
and we put it on the men to bail them
out
yeah so it's like again if you go if
we're making it a strength argument
right we're talking about strength you
hitting Dwayne The Rock Johnson he can't
hit you back then
yeah but see it's a gender thing it's
like women are always seen as the victim
even if they started it and that was my
point like with that post is like these
women will will play the victim on my
show and this has happened so many like
so many times where a girl come forward
I was abused this happened this happened
then I start asking questions and this
is the thing like in society they act
like we can't ask any questions when a
woman says abuse says I I don't say the
r word on my grape whatever but then you
say did you press charges no well why
are you publicly defaming a man's
character because they people know who
you dated
so we've had a bunch of feminists on the
show and I can hear their voices in my
head right now yeah and here's what they
would say they would say look if you
look at the statistics a woman is much
more likely to be killed or grape or
whatever by her own partner so the
biggest threat to a woman is the person
that the man that she's living with
right women are way more likely to be
men are more likely to be victims of a
violent crime yeah who cares who's the
perpetrator yeah if men are more likely
to be victims because then they'll
always say oh well I can't walk home
alone and I got attacked by a whale
because of that statement
hahaha
um yeah I just think who cares who who
does it do you not think though that if
we live in a society where we have what
biologists call sexual dimorphism like
men are different to women physically
right men of bigger stronger Etc because
women are physically on average less
able to protect themselves we should
have some sort of extra care I'm not
saying you know never hit a woman
because I can envisage a situation where
in self-defense or whatever that that
may happen but we have to teach men to
be extra careful with the strength that
they have particularly when they're
dealing with women I think we should
teach the women not to hit someone
stronger than them like I don't
understand why do we put it on the map
put on the women don't hit like you
should teach the women don't hit anyone
if you don't expect to get hit back I
agree with that I don't think anyone
should be able to press charges on a guy
if if she hit first she started it yeah
but what about if she hit first and then
it escalated and as result of that she
was severely beaten that surely should
be able to press charges because the
level of violence is disproportionate to
the situation if you hit the Dwayne The
Rock Johnson first and then he beat the
[__] out of you well it depends if
you're giving brain damage I think you
probably could press charge yes
absolutely because it'd be Grievous
bodily harm because the whole put though
it's at least in English law and
there'll be somebody who corrects me on
this it's self-defense po it's it's
self-defense if you attack me I'm
allowed to defend myself but then it
comes a point where I'm no longer
defending myself and I become the
aggressor do you see yeah I see what
you're saying I just genuinely believe
that you should not hit someone and not
expect to get hit back I that that's my
opinion I mean there is there is a logic
and I and I just don't think you can
really play the victim if you hit first
like you hit first yeah well I mean it's
one thing if it's like you shouldn't hit
people right yeah but it's just
interesting how in society it's like see
you kind of like not just you it's like
very common we always like take the
responsibility off of the women and like
put it on the men somehow yeah
hey Francis do you want to protect your
privacy cool so I do now that I'm an
International Celebrity who's appeared
on hit shows like The Joe Rogan
Experience I have to protect myself from
vicious people looking to tear me down
on the Michael Jackson of the internet
not the celebrity I would have gone for
but trust is important when picking a
VPN I don't trust anyone after she left
me she took everything Francis remember
what your lawyer said good point you can
trust expressvpn because they don't sell
your data to advertisers they've even
created software called trusted server
that means they can't store any data at
all expressvpn uses lightweight a VPN
protocol that makes user speeds faster
than ever expressvpn is now blazingly
fast you can watch HD videos with zero
buffering thousands sounds in legal fees
the great thing about expressvpn is that
you don't need any technical skills to
set up just like Francis fire up the app
and it's one button to connect One Tap
on a button was all it needed for my
entire life to disintegrate
loads of people are saying that
expressvpn is the best VPN there is
Business Insider The Verge and many
other Tech journals rate expressvpn as
the number one VPN in the world go on
Francis protect yourself with
expressvpn use or link
expressvpn.com trigger today and get an
extra three months free on a one-year
package that's
expressvpn.com trigger visit
expressvpn.com trigger to learn more she
took everything
while I think the way that you're
talking is quite blunt about it there is
some truth to what you're saying and
more broadly there's other areas where I
think that probably applies as well
right yeah just beyond the physical
stuff what like can you give us some
other examples of of what you're talking
about
things that you talk to people want to
show about
um like one thing is that men shouldn't
sleep with so many women
and they'll say like men are responsible
for all the [__] you know but I really
think it's on the horse for being [__]
no I'm
no I'm just it's like well they'll be
like well if the men weren't sleeping
around but it's like okay what percent
of men can sleep around right one out of
three men are sexless so but by this
logic like it's more on the women than
the men but it's like then they put it
on the small percentage of men that are
sleeping around does that make sense
yeah yeah it does make sense I don't
know if you've heard that argument or
not I haven't actually no yeah I've
never heard anyone blame the men for the
fact that women are doing a lot of
sleeping around that's really I hear it
all the time I always yeah they always
say like um women
um like but the men are sleeping around
when we talk about like women being
[__] yeah
it's like but the man but the men slept
with her too
but I also oh I think it's a hundred
percent the woman's fall if you get
pregnant yeah it's interesting why 100
um because we have 41 forms of birth
control
and
um the what if birth control fails
condoms what if you someone could I know
someone who was using condoms and birth
control
[Music]
okay yeah but you're saying production I
mean I don't believe in abortion but
it's legal so then you you have 100
control over who's born as a woman um
there's always a risk of pregnancy you
know so it's it is is that really fair
to say that yes
but I guess because the man only has one
choice oh I guess you could do two
vasectomies condom no condom yeah right
where the woman has like 20 choices
abortion no abortion plan b or no plan B
41 forms of birth control or No 41 forms
of birth control
um what else is there adoption no
adoption
um child support no child support
letting him have access to his kids not
letting him have access to his kids the
women have all the choice so it's like
if we have all the choice why don't we
have all the responsibility
because there's two people involved in
the creation of a child right but
there's six choices for the woman and
one for the man and the other thing like
the woman can lie where the man can't
the woman can say she's on birth control
say she took the plan B say she has an
IUD and the man could be sleeping with
someone and not even know that where the
woman knows if he's wearing a condom or
not wearing a condom so there's only one
situation like the woman is the only one
that's in a situation where she can
fully consent to everything assuming
there's no grape whatever because she
knows all the details where the man does
it yeah I mean also there's there's
several instances and of a man removing
a condoms during sex a woman noticing in
a man ejaculating in a woman
I don't believe that
I feel like that's like a cop-out to be
honest okay I feel like the girls just
say that I don't really believe it you
didn't notice okay
so what I'm curious about is what
happens when you say all this to a bunch
of random people that you've brought in
off the street
they're like super understanding
yeah I don't see that yeah I don't see
that you know those Americans don't get
it I got it I got I got whale attacked
for one of these opinions because this
girl I was doing Street interviews and
this girl was like
I can't walk home alone in life night my
life is so hard and I was just like she
was she was a whale you know what I mean
and I honestly didn't mean she was
overweight very fat yeah yeah
and so what she did was she was like
um and I was like well why don't you
just not live in a big city why don't
you just live somewhere safer why don't
you just not walk home alone at night in
a big city
men are more likely to be victims of a
violent crime and then she's like well
and then she attacks me she she tries to
she's like I'll have you you slag I
didn't know what a slag meant okay I
didn't even know what a slag was but she
was like I'll have you you slag I'll
have you and I was like have me like
what
and so then then she like knocks the mic
out of my hand my friend had to like
pull her away
and then I got it taken off of my
YouTube for privacy [__] you attacked
me and she wouldn't leave my yeah sorry
so yeah they're really understanding
yeah that's so uh I I'm kind of lost for
words a little bit because uh yeah she
was like super nice I love Britain yeah
yeah you see you see some of those goes
uh up and down High Street so on a
Saturday night yeah I mean so it just
depends on the girl like some girls
other girls say they've changed their
entire opinion I've had some girls
um say they never thought of it that way
have you always had these opinions or
has your view of this evolved over time
I've always been more conservative
um some things
I recently decided that women shouldn't
vote
decided women shouldn't involve yeah
that's a new opinion why is that okay
I'll take one for the team yeah okay why
shouldn't women vote because
um we're chemically different every
single day
right yeah and I just and like okay we
make sense hold on does that mean you
shouldn't be on YouTube then because
you're chemically different your
opinions could be [__] because they
could be yeah
should I be banned off of YouTube
doesn't have to do with voting it's like
a false equivalency okay so to me it's
like okay I feel like if [__] goes south
who's going to war
okay you know I'm gonna let me yeah let
me let me start from the beginning let
me start actually I wanna I wanna start
from how I don't want to be jumping on
this [__] train I want to start with
how I got this opinion okay I want to
start let me let me okay because I I
heard from a guy named Rolo tomasi
genius right very very smart he's a
pickup artist isn't he no no do you know
no no no no no no I don't know anything
about it what is it so um no he he a lot
of the stuff in the space of YouTube I
meant like he's just like one of the
thought leaders I would say Okay
um but he's not a pickup artist no no
okay is he the Italian comedian who's in
his 70s and talks no no it's not no he's
not no no okay sorry go ahead we keep
interrupting it
when I when I say this
crazy it does a little bit yeah
thought it was crazy okay
but what I heard was that women didn't
want to vote
so when I was like what do you mean
women didn't want to vote like the first
they threw themselves under [__]
carriages some dead yeah right but was
that women at large no no it wasn't the
majority of women back then we always
talk about the suffragettes but there
was also the anti-suffragettes yeah and
that was the majority of women when
asked if they wanted to vote said no in
the U.S I don't know what it was like
here okay you know this is U.S and I was
like why did women not want to vote
now so I read some of their their
writings from back then okay and they
basically said this is the beginning of
the breakdown of the family because back
then when you got married you became one
and you trusted your husband to make
that decision okay now that was one
argument and I was like okay well but
Society is a little different today
argument number two back then they had
to be drafted
so any woman
that wanted to vote
had to go to war because you're voting
in the U.S anyway for your
commander-in-chief because
if they go to war who's gonna have to
deal with the consequence and that's
where we're at is because
if [__] goes south and we go to war the
men are the one that are going to have
to deal with the consequences so yeah I
felt like if we want to vote we should
be equally because women want equality
equally drafted just like the men
and now you're thinking we don't have
the draft anymore right that's probably
your thought
however however we have selective
service in the U.S meaning that if a man
if there's a crisis right and we do go
to war the men have to be like like they
then can be taken to I'm butchering it a
little bit does that make sense but
and if they don't do this they're fined
a hundred thousand dollars
is that equal is that fair where we have
the same rights but we don't have the
same responsibilities if [__] goes south
I don't think that's fair so I thought
about it would I want to be in selective
service if I had to pick
my answer is no no I will give up the
right to vote to not have to do that and
I think that would be fair I think
feminists they want equality
but they don't want the responsibility
that comes with it that's my opinion
okay
now what's interesting about that is in
some countries like Israel it's men and
women through national service yeah I
don't want that so you keep me out of
that keep me
but also women are far more likely to
vote for peaceful and left-leaning party
women are more likely to rage War fun
fact the last 500 years between um night
in the last 500 years
queens were more likely to wage war than
Kings also dispute the idea of the
left-wing parties are more peaceful but
yeah